what's all the rage with non-fungible
tokens
[Music]
people are getting crazy rich selling
stuff on the internet
no i'm not talking about jeff bezos at
amazon
i'm talking about artists musicians and
creators of weird collectibles
that live only on computer disks but
that's not new you might say
well it is because what they're doing
now is selling one-of-a-kind items
that can't be replicated and can be
certified as originals
and they're doing it with a technology
called non-fungible tokens
think of it like this in the bad old
days of napster and pirate bay
if i bought a movie or a song to play on
my computer
i could then put it on the internet and
anyone could download it
without any loss of quality which is
great
unless you're the one selling the
content now the problem of distribution
replication had largely been solved by
embedding digital rights management
systems in files
but that was to protect the copyright
owner what was missing was that there
still wasn't a way for the purchaser to
prove that they
were the owner of a unique asset that
could be sold and resold but never
replicated
and that idea of exclusiveness of being
the only one in the world
able to claim ownership of a distinct
product
is the crooks upon which the human
history of collecting art
and knickknacks list enter non-fungible
tokens
making use of distributed ledger
technology and living more often than
not
on the ethereum blockchain they create a
certificate of ownership
over a digital file which can be tracked
from the person who created it
to the one who currently owns it
and that's created a boom in the digital
arts market
don't believe me a digital trading card
that displays a green homer simpson went
for three hundred and twenty thousand
dollars
the dogecoin dog went up for sale and
the source code
of the world wide web was also sold
artists known as beeple sold a high
resolution image
for 69 million dollars with the help of
christie's
and a virtual reality house that exists
nowhere in the physical world went for
520
000 and you can buy and sell horses that
live online
as non-fungible tokens and of course as
with any new technology
there's still bugs to fix for instance
there's not very much in the form of
legal precedent to certify that these
contracts will stand up in court
nor is there anything to stop a tweet
from being sold twice
on rival blockchains so as always buyer
beware
but in the meantime they're certainly
making
big bucks i'm eddie van der waals
this is decrypted for more content like
this
follow us on your favorite platforms
[Music]